Ulysses wrote in in the era of Trump and
of most Alabama Republicans voting for
an alleged serial child sex offender in
Roy Moore does the moral high-ground
matter in politics anymore you know what
Ulysses it does matter only as a
hypothetical pie-in-the-sky
campaign talking point on which you can
raise money what I mean by that is it
doesn't actually matter in that even
though Republicans in Alabama mostly
claim to be the party of morality and to
family values and of whatever else you
correctly point out that they mostly
voted for the serial alleged child sex
offender so in practice the moral
high-ground doesn't exist what matters
is is this someone who is hitting all
the right bullet points for what my
worldview is and how I choose people to
vote for the truth though is that the
moral high ground is still a really good
way to raise money and to frame yourself
as a candidate because we've seen
Republican after Republican after
Republican say that they are of the
party of Family Values that they are
religious conservatives that they are
with Jesus and with what God would want
while meanwhile they are committing
adultery they are committing fraud they
are committing acts of corruption and
whatever else but it doesn't matter
because framing yourself as taking the
moral high ground is how you still raise
money in politics in a lot of parts of
the United States so in a literal sense
to answer Ulisses question the moral
high ground doesn't matter people will
vote for you if you say the right thing
no matter what when it comes to raising
money the moral high ground is still a
very very profitable mechanism in
politics yeah I mean I think overall the
moral high ground doesn't really matter
anymore and the reason is because when
you vote for someone you vote on two
different things one is their character
yeah and the other is the policies
that's they support or oppose okay and
so even though Roy Moore's and Donald
Trump's even character was put into
question when they were running in their
respective races Republican voters could
still look at them and say well you know
there's still pro-life there's still
anti gay marriage or Oh guns so I could
put all that stuff aside because I want
the policy
that they're going to push for yes but a
lot of the policies that these
candidates espouse wouldn't even be good
for a lot of these voters so I think
what you're saying applies to social
policy to social policy even if you're
the adulterer and even if you coerced
your mistress into getting an abortion
if your position is that you're
anti-abortion then you've still got the
vote of a lot of these right-wingers the
problem though is and we saw it with the
Tea Party movement in 2010 with economic
policy a lot of these people are
straight up voting for people in spite
of the reality that the economic policy
they're espousing would be terrible for
them yeah very very good mostly for the
rich and not good for the average voter
that's more of an education concern I
would think absolutely the point too
rather than one about character moral
high-ground so Ulysses the moral high
ground exists as a fundraising mechanism
and not much else in 2017 American
politics